Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui dans
ScienceClic, la dilatation du temps.
Le temps est une notion essentielle
pour décrire notre monde.
Le temps qui passe permet de quantifier
l'évolution et le mouvement des objets.
A première vue on pourrait penser que le temps est
absolu, qu’il passe toujours au même rythme avec
une même horloge pour tout l’univers.
Mais au début du vingtième siècle,une découverte
vient bouleverser notrecompréhension : la relativité.
En relativité, le temps n’est
plus absolu, il est relatif.
Chaque objet porte son propre
temps, sa propre horloge.
Et deux horloges initialement synchronisées, en
suivant des trajets différents dans l’espace,
peuvent se retrouver et présenter un décalage.
En 1971, l’expérience est réalisée à l’aide d’horloges
atomiquesembarquées dans deux avions.
Après un voyage autour de la Terre en sens
opposés, les deux horloges initialement
synchronisées présentent désormais un décalage.
Le contenu du premier avion, horloge, passagers,
et autres objets, semble avoirvieilli 300 nanosecondes
demoins que le contenu de l’autre avion.
Un décalage parfaitement perceptible
par ce type d’horloges très précises.
Comment expliquer ce phénomène ?
Comment expliquer que l'une des deux horloges
ait mesuré une durée plus courte que l'autre ?
Le temps s’est-il dilaté ?
S’est-il écoulé plus lentement ?
Pour comprendre ce phénomène intuitivement, il
va être utile de considérer une situation qui à
première vue n'a pas vraiment de rapport.
On imagine simplement une prairie,
sur laquelle une personne A avance
tout droit, à un pas régulier.
En comptant ses pas, A mesure la distance
qu'elle parcourt à travers la prairie.
Sur cette prairie se trouvent deux arbres,
et A est orientée de sorte qu'au 20e pas,
elle franchit les deux arbres en même temps.
Maintenant une deuxième personne, B,avance
elle aussi tout droit, au même rythmeque A,
mais pas dans la même direction.
De son point de vue, B ne passe
pas les deux arbres en même temps,
elle franchit d'abord l'arbre de droite, au
15e pas, puis l'arbre de gauche, au 26e pas.
Pour A le passage des deux arbres est
simultané, mais pour B il se produit
en décalé, l'ordre de passage dépend de la
direction dans laquelle on se déplace.
Imaginons que A observe les
traces de pas laissées par B.
De son point de vue A ne perçoit pas la direction
de ces traces, elle observe uniquement qu’elles
semblent plus rapprochées que les siennes,
comme si B avait marqué des pas plus courts.
De même, pour B les traces laissées
par A semblent contractées.
En réalité A et B marchent au même rythme,
les traces sont identiquement espacées.
Il est juste question de perspective
car l’orientation est différente.
Pour finir, imaginons que A et B
marchent dans la même direction,
mais cette fois-ci la prairie n'est pas plane,
le chemin de B passe par une colline.
Encore une fois, pour A les pas de B semblent
contractés, comme s'ils étaient plus courts.
Et encore une fois il est juste question de
perspective, les pas de B sont bien réguliers,
mais ils sont orientés différemment,
ils suivent la pente de la colline,
si bien que pour A ils semblent plus courts.
Pour résumer, lorsque deux personnes comparent
leurs traces de pas, elles peuvent observer
des pas plus courts - qui semblent contractés -
d'unepart si les directions sont différentes,
etd'autre part si la surface est courbée.
Cette contraction n'est cependant qu'un effet
de perspective, en réalité les deux personnes
marchent toujours au même rythme.
Revenons à notre problème initial.
D’après la relativité, les objetsdans l’univers se déplacent
à traversune surface qu’on appelle l’espace-temps.
C'est une surface assez complexe à 4 dimensions,
mais pour simplifier on peut l’imaginerà 2 dimensions,
comme la prairie.
Dans l’espace-temps, tous les objets se déplacent,
et au cours de leurs trajectoires les horloges
de chaque objet tournent, le temps qu’ils
portent s’écoule à mesure qu'ils avancent.
Le “temps” que porte un objet est donc
l’équivalent des traces de pas dans la prairie.
Les secondes qui passent sur notre
horloge mesurent la distance que
l’on parcourt dans l’espace-temps.
Il est très important de comprendre que tous les objets,
qu’il s’agisse d’un humain, d’une pomme,
d’une étoile ou d’un atome, se déplacent
toujoursau même rythme :
en l’intervalle d’une secondenous parcourons
tous une même distance (environ300 000 kilomètres)
dans l’espace-temps.
Mais pas tous dans la même direction...
Chaque observateur porte deux axes:
un qu’il appelle le “temps”,
dirigé selon sa trajectoire, au cours
duquels’écoulent les secondes,
et l’autre axe, perpendiculaire,
qu’il appelle “l’espace”.
Un objet qui se déplace dans la même
direction que nous nous semble immobile.
L’objet est bien en mouvement
dansl’espace-temps,
mais sur l’axe qu’on appelle“espace”,
il ne change pas de position.
À l'inverse, si l'objet avance dans
une direction différente de la nôtre,
il nous semble en mouvement, sa
position varie sur l'axe “espace”.
C’est ce qu’on appelle la “vitesse”.
La “vitesse” entre deux objets représente simplement
l’angle que forment leurs trajectoires dans l'espace-temps.
Comme dans la prairie, si l’on imagine deuxévénements
qui se produisent au même instantpour nous,
ces deux événements peuvent seproduire en décalé
pour quelqu'un d'autre,qui serait orienté différemment.
La simultanéité est relative.
Attention il ne s'agit pas
d'une simple illusion d'optique,
mais bien d'une différence de référentiel.
Les deux observateurs ont des définitions différentes
de ce qu'ils appellent le "temps"et “l'espace”,
leurs axes ne sont pas les mêmes,
d’où cette différence de perception.
Comme dans la prairie, si on observe
un objetqui se déplace par rapport à nous,
on perçoitson axe “temps” selon
une perspective différente,
comme s'il s’écoulait à un rythme différent.
En réalité, les temps des deux objets s’écoulentau
même rythme, mais dans desdirections différentes.
C'est cet effet qu’on appelle
"dilatation" du temps.
On comprend bien qu’il ne s’agit
pas réellement d’une "dilatation",
le rythme du temps n’a pas changé, il est
simplement question de perspective.
Si l’on imagine deux jumeaux qui se séparent,
l'un restant sur Terre, l'autre effectuant un
aller-retour à grande vitesse dans l'espace,
les trajets n'ayant pas la même longueur dans
l'espace-temps, à leur réunion les deux
jumeaux n'auront plus le même âge.
Dans l’expérience des deux avions,
l’explication est similaire.
Les deux avions se séparent, parcourent des
trajectoires différentes dans l’espace-temps,
et il se trouve que l’une des deux
trajectoires est plus longue que l’autre,
en termes de distances dans l’espace-temps.
Les horloges n’ont pas parcouru la même distance,
et ne mesurent donc pas la même durée.
Enfin, comme pour la prairie,
si l’espace-temps est courbé,
ce qui est le cas autour d’un astre
massif comme la Terre, on va là aussi
percevoir un effet de "dilatation" du temps, les secondes
semblent passer à des rythmes différents pour
deux objets à des altitudes différentes.
Deux jumeaux qui se séparent, vivent
chacun à des altitudes différentes,
puis serejoignent, n’auront pas parcouru
la mêmedistance dans l’espace-temps,
si bien que l’undes deux aura
vieilli davantage que l’autre.
Dans la situation extrême où la pente serait
verticale, un objet s’y déplaçant semblerait
figé depuis l’extérieur, situation
analogue à l’horizon d’un trou noir.
Pour conclure, l’analogie de la prairie
donne une bonne intuition géométrique de
ce qu’on appelle le “temps” en relativité.
Les objets se déplacent tous à
travers unesurface, l’espace-temps,
et portent chacun leurspropres axes
“temps” et “espace”, si bien qu’en
étant orientés différemment, les durées et les
distances qu’ils mesurent sont différentes.
L’analogie de la prairie présente
cependant des limites, elle n'est pas
parfaitement équivalente avec la relativité.
En particulier, dans la prairie les traces
depas nous semblent contractées,
alors qu'enrelativité c'est l’inverse :
le temps d'unobjet en mouvement
nous semble dilaté.
Autre différence : dans la prairie ilest possible
de revenir sur sespas, on peut faire demi-tour.
Mais dans l'espace-temps, bien que les objets
puissent accélérer autant qu'ils le souhaitent,
changer de direction, leurs trajectoires
sont restreintes à l’intérieur d’un cône,
la géométrie particulière de l'espace-temps
les empêche de faire demi-tour.
Dans cette géométrie un peu spéciale, le
théorème de Pythagore n’est plus vrai,
cette trajectoire est plus courte que celle-ci,
et il existe une sorte de "vitesse limite",
la vitesse de la lumière,
onparle de géométrie Lorentzienne.